there is a song that is
jumping up the charts it has actually
reached number one on billboard's hot
hard rock chart
none of that fat and ugly hard rock
we're talking about the hottest hard
rock and so my producers heard this song
and they said michael you're very hip to
the jive you're one cool cat we need you
to listen to this song so that you can
analyze it for us and tell us what it
means before we do that i've got to
thank our wonderful friends over at
kamikoto kamikoto knives more from them
later first though the song zombified by
falling in reverse
take it away
okay this is a documentary so far
a bunch of zombies well for the past two
years i guess that would
basically be a documentary too
the monsters are living under your bed
because they are the voice they send
your head
this turns out to be a coven thing
that'll be so great
i'm actually somewhat hopeful this is
about coded
[Music]
oh pause
okay so this is obviously an extremely
conservative song right they've got you
have the sensor bar
so it's there's this anti-censorship
thing and then they're canceling you the
only people who use the phrase cancel in
an earnest way are conservatives because
the libs deny that they cancel anybody
so okay so now i'm i i'm willing to
predict this is actually
just an anti-fouchy screed
[Music]
[Music]
fight
the mirror is kind of an interesting
image
you gotta shut your mouth and bite your
tongue cause you don't wanna piss off
anyone
so this is interesting because usually
the the rock songs that are anti-america
are coming at it from the left like
america's this terrible oppressive
right-wing patriarchal white supremacist
place and we need to totally change
america to make it better but and this
song keeps up the rock and roll
something's wrong with the country we're
fighting against the system but what's
different is they they appear to be
recognizing that the system is actually
run by the liberals it's not
you're not actually if you're a lib
fighting for more lib things you're not
fighting against the system everyone is
on your side the government the media
the schools the the
uh administrative government all of the
universities big tech all the
corporations so you're not really doing
that this is this is quite a shift
i've only noticed this within the last
few years that it's it's become quite
clear that the liberals control the
entire
entire country they even use this word
hypnosis here which i don't know when
the video was made it was probably made
a while ago but within the past few
weeks you haven't even been allowed to
use the phrase mass hypnosis or mass
formation psychosis to describe what's
going on the last two years because all
of the libs who were hypnotizing you and
driving everyone crazy are
responding to that and saying no beep
boop no psychosis no beep beep boop no
hypnosis i'm getting very sleepy but
there's no hypnosis and the
musicians here are recognizing obviously
something has gone wrong
fellas i have the perfect gift for that
lovely lady in your life this
valentine's day that would be knives
kamikoto taps into more than 800 years
of traditional techniques from honshu
japan kamikoto also uses steel sourced
only from mills in japan and each blade
is crafted using techniques that have
been honed and perfected by generations
of knife smiths each knife comes in a
beautiful heavy duty ash wood box makes
sure that the knife is stored safely
also makes kamikodo a great gift i
really love these knives sweet little
elisa really loves these knives too when
you can go and present
a really high quality sort of
kitchen utensil like this it can make a
really really wonderful gift i love it
elisa loves it you're gonna love it too
kami kodo is currently having a massive
valentine's day sale and on top of that
sale you can get an additional 50 bucks
off any purchase you make with discount
code knowles click the link below or go
to kamikoto.com knowles and use promo
code noles to save an extra 50 bucks
today
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
pause
this is setting up a sequel song about
immigration you see the first one is
clearly about kovid and the the liberal
elite just clamping down on all of us
and then but now the next one is going
to be the illegal alien invasion that
i'm it's either a prediction or a plea
please make it i love too
that the solution to this is not some
too clever by half way of resolving the
issue in this very no you just shoot the
zombies in the head
[Music]
pick it metaphorically
pumping us with lies like it's
formaldehyde
fight
i like godzilla
wow
i really like this idea not only because
of the
simplest reading of it which is
basically that the libs have surrendered
their free thought and their faculties
of reason and they just do whatever dr
fauci tells them to do and they walk
around like zombies there's a great old
clip of bob hope
who was was
talking to a doctor and
and the doctor said
you know zombies they have no will of
their own they just wander around
blindly doing whatever you tell them to
do not thinking not caring and bob hope
says you mean like democrats it's a clip
that always goes around every election
season so it's it's not merely saying
that
it's saying something even deeper
they are
pumping us full of formaldehyde
right they're
they're killing us
they're treating us like we're dead
bodies but we're still reanimated we're
still kind of moving around we just
don't have any free will we're not we're
existing but we're not really living
and that is
a great way to describe what's happened
for the past two years with covid not
merely that people got brainwashed or
hypnotized
but that we have been deprived the
opportunity really to live
you can't go to work can't go to church
can't go shopping in a lot of places we
still we can't go to a lot of
restaurants now especially if you're not
willing to take the fouchy algae
even the imagery of being injected being
pumped full of something obviously has a
connection here to the covid measures in
the vaccines
but
this distinction between merely existing
like some undead zombie and actually
living and doing the things that really
animate us and animate our society
that's a really important distinction
sure people have been alive for the past
couple years
but they haven't really been living and
we need to get back to living really
really like that message excellent job
falling in reverse
[Music]
[Music]
you